How's the weather today, Mom?
It is very cold and windy outside.
I'd better put on a warm coat and pants.
Oops, I can't get into this dress.
You gained some weight during the vacation.
You're right.
I need to go on a diet.
Where is your sister?
She is next to the door.
She is wearing a green sweater.
The bear was cold, cold, very cold.
Squish, squash, squeeze, he got into the warm mitten.
The fox was cold, cold, very cold.
Squish, squash, squeeze, he got into the mitten with the bear.
The rabbit was cold, cold, very cold.
Squish, squash, squeeze, she got into the warm mitten.
The blue jay was cold, cold, very cold.
Squish, squash, squeeze, he got into the mitten after the rabbit.